مرحباً، اسمي Katy Beslado
أنا مديرة استراتيجية IBM Quantum
وبحوث التطبيقات، وأنا هنا لأدحض
أكبر عدد ممكن من الخرافات حول الحوسبة الكمومية
في ستين ثانية.
هذه واحدة من الحقائق الجميلة المطلقة، إنها حقيقية
وعندنا أجهزة على IBM Cloud يقدر أي شخص يوصل لها.
نعم، بس فقط لأشياء معينة تتفوق فيها فعلاً،
مثل الرياضيات المعقدة جداً التي يعمل بها الكون
لكن لو تبي تعمل جداول بيانات أو إيميلات، استخدم
حاسوبك الشخصي.
نعم، من الناحية النظرية، بس مو
في القريب العاجل، ما في أحد يصنع حاسوباً قادراً على ذلك
حتى الآن، وللمستقبل المنظور نحن على المسار الصحيح،
وحين نصل لهناك راح نغير طريقة حماية
المعلومات.
هذا خاطئ تماماً، أجهزة الحاسوب الكمومي
مختلفة جذرياً
وتستخدم قوانين الطبيعة لمعالجة المعلومات،
الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم يعمل على أجهزة كلاسيكية قديمة الطراز
لكننا نؤمن بأنهما سيتشاركان في المستقبل.
هذا مو صحيح، عندنا منظومة هائلة
من الشركات الناشئة والأكاديميات والمختبرات الوطنية وشركاء الصناعة
يستخدمون أجهزتنا كل يوم.
لأ، الحوسبة المستوحاة من الكم موجودة
منذ زمن طويل وتعمل على أجهزة كلاسيكية، وهي
لن تحقق وعود الحوسبة الكمومية أبداً،
لو كنت تريد حوسبة كمومية حقيقية، لازم تعملها بأجهزة كمومية فعلية
حقيقية